Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to
AFTERLIFE: The Game.
Now, since we're dead,
I'm assuming that we can take all the time in the world.
We don't need to be in a blind mad rush
to get into the grave,
so here we gooo!
*Cheery jazz music starts*
Aw shit.
God dammit!
'FLY!' Ah, shit.
Oh. Ohhh!
It's like Flappy Bird!
Ahh, isn't this beautiful and delightful?
Ohhh, the lovely countryside.
Hi Moon!
How're you doing?
I'm only-
Oh hey, how's it going, spiders?
How you be?
Oh you cool, you cool with me, spider bros!
You cool. Okay.
I guess we flew into heaven? What the hell happened?
'Clean your computer'? OH!
Holy shit!
What the fuck-
Oh.
'Interracial-' Oh my god!
'TINY box Tim'?
Oh, 'Silly banana Septipl-'
Oh my god!
Oh no!
'Interracial man contemplates a banana'
I'm IN HERE!
YEAH!
THAT'S ME!
Oh my god, that's me!
OHH-
Wait.
Oh shit.
"After your death your computer was given to your youngest grandchild Timmy."
"When he first opened it he saw stuff that scarred him for life."
*laughing a bit* "He now resides in a mental hospital and crafts cute little stickers from post-it notes"
*Laughs*
Oh my god...
*sniffle*
Okay.
Alright, let's try this-
I-I think I get, I think I get it now.
Okay, so I'm supposed to delete these.
'Cake eating', 'Irish master sits while talking about fans',
'MARKIPLIER LOVES YOU'
It's literally me?! Oh my god,
that's, that's n- [incomprehensible]- a thing.
Okay. Umm...
What is... Oh, okay.
'Special porn'? Oh, 'More porn', 'Porn',
God, so much porn!
Ugh, so much porn!
Yeaugh!
Protect what?
What am I protecting?
*High-pitched squeals*
Ninjas! Ah axes!
Oh POOP!
Who's throwing all these poop and axe?
Oh my god, porcupurne!
Oh, get outta here!
I don't know how this ghost is managing to do all this, she was-
Hello!
Alrighty then!
'Revenge', 'Drag'.
How?
Well alright then, goodbye!
Alright, Alan!
I don't know what you did, Alan.
Are you scared?
*Ghostly voice* Have you been properly spoooked?
Oooh~
*Regular voice* It took me a while to get what I was doing.
Oh HI!
Hi Jack!
How's it- Yeah!
YEAH!
Get it!
Get those subs, Jack!
Get those subs!
Ohhh, the sweet deli-
*loud disturbing scream*
What the fuck was that!?
Holy shit!
I was not ready for that. Okay!
Let's try this again.
Double-click mode!
*Manly grunt*
*Soft screaming in background*
Bye Jack!
I guess you died.
'Make them laugh'.
"What's grean, fuzzy, and if it fell out of a tree it would kill you?"
Ja-Jack?
Ja- "I bet you're expecting to hear a joke ab-"
"That's the..."
*puke noises*
A pool table!
"What's the difference between a snowman and snow-woman?"
The snowballs!
"What do you call a Mexican do-drowning in mayonnaise?"
'Sinko de mayo.'
Oh, come on now.
"Which bees produce milk?"
Boo-bees!
"What do you call a sheep with no legs?"
... A cloud.
YAAAAh! I'm the best ghost!
Wooooo!
Okay.
*Rave music starts*
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
*Grunts*
*Realization laugh*
Jesus!
*Laughing more*
Oh man, I'm so good at whatever the hell this is.
YAAAH!
*Rave music stops, happy bgm resumes*
Aww, I don't even get to dance!
Ah, shit.
Oh!
'Dunk it'?
Alright.
Hep.
Uh-huh, I know.
Oh I can- Ohhh, you failed!
God, that's terrible for you.
Huuup!
Ah, shit.
Well, I mean-
Oh, what!?
You asshole!
Don't-Don't try that shit!
HUUUP!
BACK RIM!
WOAH!
N-ni-nice.
Tha-that was, that was a good one, you almost had that.
You almost had that, buddy.
YEAH!
WOOOHOHOHOOO!
Alright, 'dress up'.
How?
*laughing* In man clothes? Dress up-
OH DEADPOOL!
Oh I didn't even s-
Aww, I wanna do Deadpool without a shirt!
Oh, in his underwear!
Yeah!
Okay, there we go then!
Alright.
"The only thing you should fear more than Ghos-" aww, fuck off.
Alright fine, full Deadpool.
*gross grunt*
How 'bout that?
'Collect' what, souls?
Oh, shit.
Oh! I'm-I'm literally Deadpool!
Oh.
Oh shit!
Oh god!
Uh eughhh, it's so hard to walk!
I'm a ghost, why am I trying to walk?
Ah, shit.
Where's the chimichangas?
Ah, fuck off.
Fuck off!
HuAa!
Aw, shit.
Ah shit, dude!
Ah fuck... Agh, I got it.
Ah god, there's more, why's there gonna be more?
Oh, what kind of trick or treating bullshit is this?
*odd sounds* Ah, fuck off!
*High pitched wail*
Did I get it?
YEAH!
I did it!
YEAH!!
"Like a drunken Russian teenager."
Oh, okay.
'COLLECT!'
Oh, what the fuck!
I just did this!
Can I get through here?
No I cannot. Fuck.
Oh I- I- I then, I- I
I HAD it!
I had it!
God dammit, I had it!
Why did it say that I didn't have it?
I HAD it!
Oh, where does the razor blade go?
I don't know, doesn't matter to me, I'm a ghost!
Oh shit, what did I do wrong?
WHAT DID I DO WRONG?
Oh okay, we're fine.
I thought I- woooh, okay.
'Bust Out'?
Of what!?
I'm a-
I'm a ghost!
I'm literally a ghost, what am I-
What the hell is this?
Oh, is this the uh,
the Ghostbusters' secret super special
Bullshit Trapifier?
Oh god.
Eeaaeh!
Guuh!
I'm outta here, baby!
Oh OOOOh!
Okay. Choose what?
'Highway to hell', 'stairway to heaven'. Alright!
Highway to hell it is!
Always my choice.
Oh! Hey ducky!
What-
Am I-
Oh! I have-
Oh, I didn't know that I was in control here.
Why is...
Why is hell filled with ducks?
Aw, shit.
Uhh...
I don't wanna touch any of these ducks!
I know how dirty they are, I guess.
Okay...
Yeah!
'Welcome to Hell!'
Okay! *giggle*
Oh, yeah!
Yeah! I did it!
Okay!
Goooood!
Greeeeat!
This was an experience!
Glad I did this.
Coooool!
*Horn*